appell des bundespräsidenten frank
walter steinmeier ruft in der korona
krise auf zusammenzuhalten
wir spüren miteinander unser einstehen
füreinander unsere solidarität ist jetzt
existenziell wichtig in den usa sind
bereits mehr als 1000 menschen an kubik
19 gestorben am härtesten betroffen ist
die metropole new york und umgang mit
soziale distanz deutsche astronauten
geben tipps gegen einsamkeit und
lagerkoller
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hobby guten abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag schön dass sie dabei sind
wie außergewöhnlich die zeiten sind
zeigt der bundespräsident zum zweiten
mal innerhalb von zehn tagen spricht er
die bürger per video an um zu danken um
mut zu machen aber vor allem um zu
appellieren haltet abstand und gebt acht
aufeinander
patricia wieder 'wir reden halten
persönliche gespräche führen dabei
appellieren und mahnen das ist das was
ein bundespräsident tun kann
doch in diesen zeiten geht das nicht
bundespräsident steinmeier wendet sich
daher wieder per video an die bürger und
mahnt abstand halten nur der verzicht
verhindert dass wir dauerhaft verlieren
was wir leben
die überwältigende mehrheit in unserem
lande hat das verstanden und handelt
danach
dafür danke ich ihm steinmeier hat viel
telefoniert in den letzten tagen vor
allem mit denen die das land am laufen
halten mit ärzten pflegern polizisten
und mitarbeitern in supermärkten sie
alle sie sind die heldinnen und helden
in der korona krise normalerweise würde
der bundespräsident durch das land
reisen bürgergespräche vor ort führen
doch in corona zeiten ist das nicht
möglich ebenso wenig wie staatsbesuche
daher nutzt der andere form für seine
appelle zur internationalen
zusammenarbeit weltweit vernetzt
arbeiten forscherinnen und forscher
zusammen um impfstoff therapien und
gegenstrategien zu entwickeln
und je besser politik wirtschaft und
wissenschaft zusammenarbeiten desto
schneller wird das gelingen
trotz physischem abstand könne man
einander näher sein als je zuvor so die
heutige botschaft aus dem präsidialamt
die amerikanische johns hopkins
universität zählt in deutschland bereits
43 1646 nachgewiesene infektionen 239
menschen sind demnach gestorben das ist
der stand heute 18 uhr 30
momentan werden die kliniken mit den
fallzahlen noch fertig doch auch hier
sind die kapazitäten begrenzt und so
bereiten sich die krankenhäuser
deutschlandweit auch auf zweiten vor in
denen sie mehr patienten haben als sie
behandeln können wird auch spiekermann
berichtet die furcht der ärzte und
pfleger in kliniken ist greifbar
die pandemie ist in deutschland erst am
anfang was aber wenn die intensivbetten
nicht reichen schwerwiegende
entscheidungen müssen getroffen werden
noch gehen die meisten ärzte nicht davon
aus dass es zu einem horror szenario
kommt vorbereitet sein will man aber
trotzdem wer wird im schlimmsten fall
behandelt und mehr nicht das alter zum
beispiel sich alleine spielt nicht die
rolle er spielen ganz klar die schwere
der untergang der guten grund gegangen
eine ganz klare rolle es gibt
handlungsempfehlungen von mehreren
medizinischen fachgesellschaften für
intensivmediziner etwa einer weit
fortgeschrittenen lungen oder
krebserkrankungen oder auch bei schwerer
herzschwäche könnten patienten bei
dramatischen engpässen nachrangig oder
nicht mehr behandelt werden
andere länder sind schon an diesem
dramatischen punkte straßburg im elsass
ein epizentrum der epidemie in
frankreich dort erklärten ärzte über
80-jährige würden nicht mehr beatmet
schwerstkranke jüngere wurden heute mit
einem zug in eine weniger betroffene
region gebracht um die intensivstation
zu entlasten
noch gibt es keine therapie händeringend
suchen wissenschaftler nach lösungen
medikamente gegen malaria und hiv
könnten möglicherweise auch gegen das
corona virus wirken
wir wollen möglichst sofort verfügbare
medikamente ausprobieren in ihrer
wirkung für diese neue erkrankung wir
müssen zeit gewinnen
durch diese pragmatische maßnahme zeit
gewinnen auch für einen impfstoff bis
dahin wird es wohl heißen abstand
minister sparen appelliert an die
menschen sich an die weitreichende
kontaktsperre zu halten wir können dann
nach ostern möglicherweise über eine
veränderung reden wenn wir bis ostern
alle miteinander konsequenz sind
planbare operationen wurden verschoben
gebraucht werden könnte jedes intensiv
bett jedes beatmungsgerät warten auf die
pandemiewelle gesundheitsminister sparen
sagt noch sei es die ruhe vor dem sturm
es gibt viele dinge in diesen tagen wir
können warten doch die spargelernte
beispielsweise die nicht entsprechend
frustriert sind die bauern über das
einreiseverbot für saisonarbeiter und
300.000 erntehelfer sind in der
deutschen landwirtschaft beschäftigt die
meisten kommen aus osteuropa
jetzt im märz werden 35.000 saison
arbeitskräfte gebraucht im mai
normalerweise sogar noch mehr etwa
85.000 malin ihlau über die schwierige
ernte in krisenzeiten
sie sind unter den letzten die noch ins
land kommen durften bevor gestern das
einreiseverbot für erntehelfer verhängt
wurde jörg heuer spargelbauer aus dem
niedersächsischen burgwedel hat noch 60
helfer aus rumänien einfliegen lassen
doch eigentlich bräuchte er noch viel
mehr
nicht nur für die anstehende
spargelernte der landwirt appelliert an
die politik der einreise stopp darf
nicht so lange dauern dass uns
möglichkeiten geschaffen werden dass wir
ganz einfach die ernte einbringen können
ansonsten geht das wirklich den
betrieben ins mark und da stehen dann
auch existenzen auf dem spiel
wir haben nur diese eine saison wir
können das nicht verlegen wie eine messe
wie lange diese maßnahme gilt dazu noch
keine klare ansage aus berlin die
landwirtschaftsministerin versucht zu
beruhigen man nennt es auch auf sicht
fahren
es gibt dinge die muss man dann regel im
prozess und da sind wir sehr pragmatisch
gerade unterwegs ernte hilfe plattformen
im netz sollen dann rasch abhilfe
schaffen bund und länder wollen mit
diesen initiativen neue helfer im land
gewinnen die wegen der korona krise
nicht arbeiten dürfen
doch vom erntehelfer per mausklick hält
spargelbauer jörg heuer nicht viel hält
das für eine illusion dass wir jetzt
sagen wir wollen mit studenten oder
schülern die spargelernte auf die reihe
bringen das wird nichts das wird nicht
funktionieren
spargelstechen ist eine schwere arbeit
das ist kein vorwurf an die jungen
menschen die meinen das gut aber die
erfahrung hat gezeigt das funktioniert
ganz einfach nicht die sorge bleibt wie
es weitergeht denn auch andere
gemüsekulturen müssten derzeit gepflanzt
werden ohne erfahrene erntehelfer wird
das schwierig an der deutsch
tschechischen grenze gibt es jetzt doch
eine ausnahmeregelung gestern hieß es
noch dass der übergang für alle
berufspendler dicht ist jetzt darf
medizinisches personal aus tschechien
doch weiterhin nach deutschland
begründung diesen berufen kommen eine
schlüsselaufgabe zu im kampf gegen
korona für alle anderen pendler ist die
grenze seit mitternacht geschlossen mit
den maßnahmen will tschechien die
weitere ausbreitung des corona virus
verhindern
zwei internationale gipfel an einem tag
früher undenkbar heute realität die
kanzlerin hat im home-office per
video-konferenz erst mit den staats und
regierungschefs der g20 gruppe
gesprochen und dann an einem virtuellen
eu gipfel teilgenommen das ziel in einer
zeit in der sich die nationalstaaten
abschotten die internationale
zusammenarbeit wieder in gang zu bringen
eine herausforderung für die
eu-institutionen zeigt anne gellinek das
gab es noch nie in europa eine
plenarsitzung des europaparlaments fast
ohne abgeordnete nur ein häuflein
parlamentarier ist gekommen die meisten
stimmen von zu hause ab
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
spricht vor leeren sitzen und zeichnet
ein düsteres bild die geschichte der
letzten wochen ist eine schmerzhafte als
europa wirklich füreinander da sein
musste haben zu viele zunächst nur an
sich selbst gedacht das bild einer
unsolidarischen eu in der jedes land für
sich selbst kämpft wird durch solche
aktionen noch verstärkt russland und
china liefern mit großem
propagandistischen aufwand
beatmungsgeräte und schutzmasken an
italien
der video gipfel zu dem sich die eu
staats und regierungschefs am nachmittag
zusammen schalten soll diesem eindruck
widersprechen
mittlerweile ist hilfe zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten angelaufen
ein gemeinsamer vorrat an medizinischer
ausrüstung soll angeschafft werden
doch nun droht neuer streit wie kann die
europäische wirtschaft am besten
unterstützt werden eine gruppe von neuen
regierungschefs um italien spanien
frankreich bringt vor dem gipfel eine
alte idee ins spiel
eurobonds gemeinsame schulden der eu
staaten viele nordeuropäer und die
bundesregierung sind nicht begeistert
die chancen auf durchsetzung eher gering
der video gipfel soll das zerstrittene
bild der eu korrigieren
immerhin an den binnengrenzen wollen die
europäer fortan besser zusammenarbeiten
auch in den usa wächst die angst dass
kliniken und helfer die steigende anzahl
an infizierten nicht bewältigen können
denn landesweit werden es immer
schneller immer mehr die johns hopkins
universität m zählt inzwischen mehr als
75.000 fälle besonders betroffen new
york city mehr als 20.000 menschen haben
sich hier angesteckt 280 starben an den
folgen
nun drängt die metropole verzweifelt auf
hilfe johannes hano
die new york city bereiten sie sich auf
das schlimmste vor sind diese bilder die
die menschen nervös machen
in der stadt werden provisorische
leichenhalle aufgebaut falls die
vorhandenen den kommenden tagen und
wochen nicht mehr ausreichen soll die
situation in den krankenhäusern sei
schon jetzt dramatisch erzählt ein arzt
es ist die hölle bibel ich erzähle dir
keinen mist die leute kommen rein werden
intubiert sterben und der kreislauf
beginnt von neu die infektions und
sterberaten steigen rasant mehr als
20.000 infizierte jetzt in der stadt 280
menschen sind bislang an der krankheit
gestorben
nine eleven war nichts im vergleich zu
dem was wir jetzt erleben
damals waren wir bereit aber es kam
keine überlebenden und jetzt kommen
einfach immer mehr alle altersgruppen
macht euch nichts vor wir sind nicht nur
die alten sterben
vor den krankenhäusern werden die
schlangen immer länger immer mehr
menschen mit symptomen warten auf tests
new york ist das epizentrum der krise in
den usa
der präsident ist mittlerweile besorgt
wir haben viel zeit mit new yorks
offiziellen verbracht in die stadt ist
bei weitem der größte hotspot ihnen
stehen schwere zeiten bevor
und dann kam am morgen noch die
nachricht dass die ersten zwei
supermärkte vorübergehend bis zur
desinfektion dichtmachen weil sich
angestellte infiziert hatten alles keine
guten nachrichten
new york die sonst lebendige vibrierende
stadt wird wie von furcht der stadt die
ruhe vor dem großen sturm das normale
leben ist praktisch zum erliegen
gekommen die krankenhäuser füllen sich
immer schneller eine der reichsten
städte der welt kämpft darum die
kontrolle zu behalten in dieser krise
new york stehen schwere tage und wochen
bevor die us-marine bereitet sich auf
einen katastropheneinsatz in new york
vor
so medizinische unterstützung wird sie
ein krankenhaus schiff mit 1000 betten
schicken heute wurde auch bekannt dass
sich die zahl der anträge auf
arbeitslosenunterstützung in den usa
verzehnfacht hat el mati wissen in
washington
was sagt das aus über die größte
volkswirtschaft der welt ja das ist der
größte monatliche anstieg den man hier
in den usa seit 1982 zu verzeichnen hat
3,3 millionen menschen haben sich
arbeitslos gemeldet das ist eine rate
von etwa 5,5 prozent und experten
befürchten dass die im april noch weiter
hoch schnellen kann dann rechnet man
hier mit bis zu 40 millionen arbeitslos
gemeldeten deswegen ist das hilfspaket
aus dem amerikanischen kongress so
wichtig der notenbankchef
jerome paul hat heute morgen gesagt dass
amerika sich wohl in einer rezession
jetzt befinde aber sei er hat eine
untypische rezession wenn die ganzen
ausgangssperren irgendwann wieder
aufgehoben werden wenn das virus besiegt
ist dann könnte man auch ganz schnell
wieder zu einer gut funktionierenden
laufenden wirtschaft zurückkehren
das klingt ein bisschen nach
zweckoptimismus genau wie der brief den
der us-präsident gerade an die
gouverneure geschrieben hat darin
verspricht er schnell ganz viele
testeinrichtungen im land um dann ganz
schnell auf dieser basis entscheiden zu
können welche regionen wieder ihre
wirtschaft eröffnen können aber und ich
glaube das ist die realistischere
einschätzung der notenbank chef sagt
dann wiederum dass die derzeit bahn des
ganzen am ende nur vom virus bestimmt
wird und nicht von irgendwelchen
regierungsmitgliedern oder von den
medizinern selber dankeschön für diese
informationen aus washington mrt wissen
wenn diese pandemie schon reiche
industrienationen so überfordert
dann ahnt man was auf ärmere länder
zukommt wenn dort die zahlen steigen
fast ein fünftel der weltbevölkerung
lebt in indien auch dort gilt ein
ausgangsverbot und die polizei versucht
es auch mit irritierenden methoden
durchzusetzen normen odenthal
keiner soll mehr unterwegs sein auf den
straßen indiens und die polizei ist
nicht gerade zimperlich bei der
durchsetzung ohrfeigen und stockhiebe
für die ungehorsamen 1,3 milliarden
menschen sollen nicht mehr vor die tür
mindestens drei wochen lang es gilt die
größte ausgangssperre der welt die
polizei hat die reifen einer rikscha
kaputt gemacht aber wenn ich nicht
fahren darf verdiene ich kein geld und
habe nichts zu essen zu hause bleiben
wie geht das wenn man keins hat
millionen inder sind bettelarm und
polizei war hier und wollte mich
vertreiben
aber ich habe gesagt ich kann nicht ich
weiß nicht wohin dann sind sie wieder
weg
anderswo sorgen die behörden für
freundlichere bilder polizisten
verteilen lebensmittel in den slums wo
tagelöhner ansonsten ohne lohn und brot
sind die beamten so scheint es haben
freie hand bei der wahl der mittel
dieser entscheidet sich für eine portion
demütigung werdet ihr noch mal die
regeln brechen
nein die leute haben keinen verstand die
ganze welt hat ein problem dieses virus
dagegen müssen wir vorgehen aber die
hier verstehen die neuen regeln nicht
seine regeln seine strafen sofort an ort
und stelle kniebeugen
man könnte schmunzeln aber dafür ist die
lage zu ernst
trotz der ausgangssperre in indien
konnten etwa 400 deutsche ausgeflogen
werden
entsprechend erleichtert zeigten sich
viele und bedanken sich bei der
deutschen botschaft bundesregierung
reiseveranstalter und die airlines
hatten bis gestern mehr als 150.000
deutsche staatsbürger aus dem ausland
zurück gebracht etwa 50.000 weitere die
noch feststecken sollen folgen corona
krise auch in israel für die politische
krise im land zeichnet sich aber eine
lösung ab
oppositionsführer ganz ist von der
knesset überraschend zum
parlamentspräsidenten gewählt worden das
wird als beleg dafür gewertet dass er
sich mit regierungschef netanjahu auf
eine große koalition geeinigt hat bisher
hatten sich die rivalen mit ihren
parteien bündnissen gegenseitig
blockiert fragen wir nach bei nicola
albrecht
tel aviv warum geht jetzt was so lange
unmöglich schien die große koalition
ja es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein
dass israel inmitten der korona krise
eine neue regierung bekommt und zwar vor
allem weil es premier netanjahu
geschafft hat einen keil in das
oppositionsbündnis zu treiben das zu
spalten so dass benny gantz mit einem
teil seiner bündnispartner und netanjahu
mit seinem rechten parteien block
gemeinsam eine regierung bilden können
sie nennen es eine einheitsregierung
part des deals ist auch dass netanyahu
für mindestens anderthalb jahre noch
premierminister bleibt also er hat damit
sein ziel erreicht möglicherweise wird
noch heute nacht unterschrieben
dank in die cola nach tel aviv zurück
nach deutschland für den bau einer bombe
mit dem bio kampfstoff re ziehen
in köln ist ein 31-jähriger islamist zu
zehn jahren verurteilt worden
mit seiner frau hatte er 250 stahlkugeln
beschafft und sprengstoff hergestellt
nach ansicht des düsseldorfer
oberlandesgerichts waren die
anschlagsvorbereitungen weit
fortgeschritten
dafür hatte das ehepaar aus tausenden
rizinus samen das hochgiftige rizin
produziert mit der streubombe sollten
viele menschen getötet werden um die
ausbreitung des corona virus zu
verlangsamen gelten seit gerade mal vier
tagen die ausgangs beschränkungen in
deutschland eine herausforderung für
alle ein echter experte in sachen
isolation ist alexander gerst 166 tage
verbrachte er bei seiner letzten mission
im all
was hilft gegen einsamkeit und
lagerkoller
dazu haben der astronaut und seine
kollegen heute online tipps gegeben
linken klinger hat aufmerksam zugehört
für den studenten bernard wenigen rat
kommt das besondere angebot der esa im
internet heute nachmittag gerade richtig
seine prüfungen sind verschoben jetzt
hört er sich die ratschläge der
astronauten für diese schwierige zeit
der isolation an routine sei notwendig
das ist glaube ich auch richtig jetzt in
so eine sache wie sondergarantien also
ich habe das hier auch ich habe arbeite
ich stehe auch zur gleichen zeit auf wie
wir nicht normal zur arbeit gehe ich
arbeiten tag durch und dann abends habe
ich dann meine private projekte die ich
hier durch sie 362 tage hat alexander
gerst bereits im all verbracht auf der
internationalen raumstation iss
auch der ehemalige astronaut thomas
reiter kennt die einsame situation
abgeschnitten von der welt gut 350 tage
weltraumerfahrung im interview mit uns
sagt er was neben einem festen
tagesablauf noch wichtig ist dass man
rücksicht natürlich aufeinander nimmt
dass man sich darüber im klaren ist dass
man voneinander abhängig ist dass man
möglich miteinander gearbeitet und dass
man vielleicht auch hin und wieder mal
sagt ok ich muss nicht zurückziehen auch
das ist sehr wichtig dass man auch mal
eine ecke hat wo man für sich sein kann
und man seine ruhe haben kann
bernard wenigen grad ist für die tipps
dankbar ansatz das mal zu hören weil die
us und irgendwie das perfekte beispiel
für leute die halt die ganze in
quarantäne sind ihren auftritt im netz
nutzten die astronauten aber auch noch
für einen appell an alle jetzt sei
disziplin gefragt von jedem disziplin
und solidarität die überall im land ganz
unterschiedliche blüten treibt studenten
zum beispiel die online eine corona
school gründen und schülern kostenlos
nachhilfe anbieten oder hoteliers die
ihre betten dem klinikpersonal zur
verfügung stellen
julia schröter hat mehr plastikkanister
stadt flaschen anstelle von edlen
schnäpsen geht bei einem
traditionsunternehmen im erzgebirge
gerade literweise desinfektionsmittel
vom hof da wird ja als
spirituosen-hersteller die entsprechende
technik da haben also das heißt große
mischwerke es ist also keine hexerei
auch dann das fördert das infektions mit
ausstellen zu können
hygiene ist auch ein thema bei
brummifahrer
viele raststätten haben wegen corona
geschlossen damit die trucker trotzdem
duschen können stellt ein spediteur im
münsterland seine waschräume zur
verfügung
hilfe für die die für uns alle unterwegs
sind es muss mal was sehen dass das was
die eben brauchen
draußen dass das auch da ist sprich
toiletten duschen parkplatz ein
ständchen vor dem altersheim so tut
albert ritter mit seiner antiken
kirmesorgel gutes und das obwohl
schausteller wie er gerade selbst viele
sorgen haben
ihm ist es wichtig den senioren die
wegen corona keinen besuch bekommen
dürfen
eine freude zu machen und auch das ist
für den guten zweck an einer art drive
in verschenkt ein großer knödel
hersteller aus der oberpfalz tonnenweise
kloßteig den die geschlossenen
restaurants nicht mehr abnehmen
wer will kann spenden der erlös geht an
die diakonie und auch im fußball gibt es
eine ziemlich einmalige hilfsaktion die
vier deutschen champions league klubs
bayern münchen borussia dortmund rb
leipzig und bayer leverkusen geben rund
20 millionen euro für erst- und
zweitliga-vereine die wegen der korona
krise um ihre existenz bangen
das geld kommt in einen sollen da topf
und die deutsche fußball liga
entscheidet je nach bedürftigkeit über
die verteilung und auch heute wieder
gibt es gleich nach uns ein zdf spezial
zur kuba krise
und mit der neuen zdf heute app bleiben
sie jederzeit auf dem laufenden
dort erfahren sie auf einen blick das
wichtigste außerdem gibt es viele
interessante hintergrund-berichte morgen
gibt es nicht nur viel sonne sondern es
wird auch milder wie lange das erzählt
gleich katja honnefer claus kleber freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um 10
morgen ist hier wieder petra gerster
dran alles gute ihnen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren diese
nacht wird nicht mehr überall
sternenklar sondern zum teil auch wolkig
und deswegen ist es längst nicht mehr so
kalt wie in den vergangenen nächten und
sie warten tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
plus vier grad im rhein-main-gebiet und
minus vier grad in oberschwaben und
morgen erwarten uns dann frühlingshafte
werte meist zwischen 13 und 19 grad und
nur entlang der küsten von ost und
nordsee ist es bei acht bis zwölf grad
kälter dazu scheint morgen wieder häufig
die sonne es ziehen allerdings bei
leichtem nordostwind auch einige
wolkenfelder durch auch am samstag gibt
es noch ähnliches frühlingswetter dann
aber kommt der temperatur und
wettersturz am sonntag bei drei bis elf
am montag bei 9 bis 9 grad
schönen abend noch